Tim Roth sit down of course she did
welcome oh oh there it is but you're
good
chairs with wheels on it they can be
very very harmful touchy very very
harmful well welcome to the show man
thank you you are you are you excited
for people to see 10 star cause I mean
you're a you're the star of the show
you're in it and it seems like it's a
it's a it's a big it's a big time
commitment to do a season of television
I don't before right of course but I did
it in a very different way I'd not I've
not done that kind of where you do a
character across like 10 episodes we
have greatness there the one that I've
done before was just that everything was
standalone so he's just telling a story
a week
yeah which was hilarious I just thought
this is worth a shot yeah so you give it
a go so that was like 55 episodes at
that same fella right and then so then
Diaz weird do you become exhausted with
the character like how many stories does
this guy have to tell no what actually
because I never watch stuff that I'm in
no way mean are you used to 15 years ago
I kind of about it's about the time and
I started when I directed that I stopped
really unless I'm trapped in a cinema
and I can't get out there is that there
a certain movie that made you say I'm
not looking at my face anymore up on
that screen yeah I know I think the
public isn't I think you get you get a
better shot if you're not sort of pretty
boy like I see you get the longer life
you got ass when you've got a look well
no you just paste the English that's why
I'm a terrible actor though I just bat
my eyelashes I think you get a longer
run if you if you can if people get a
bit hooked on your way but that's okay
what's cool and you don't go through the
thing I mean we're talking about older
actors and actresses like you'd have to
worry about people being like oh he
doesn't look like he did when he was
young no you just keep looking weird
weird you got to start down here right
you got to set that bar low nice
as long as you're with it I know but
there is a when I came out here um there
weren't that many British actors about
there was me and Gary right Gary almond
that was it and Gary came out to do
that's terrible competition we've done
two films together and um and he was I
mean I I swam on stage mm-hmm you know
he was an incredible stage actor that's
something that you guys missed out on
yeah but anyway but but we both of us
looked like we've been dragged through a
hedge backwards basically you know but
we actually did talk about about there's
no one there's no English people out
here they everyone has to look a certain
way to be in films right what about the
Harry Dean sentence of the world what
about those guys that there are the
character that's you know an odd odd
journey and it's such a great time
because I feel like nobody's got a
British accent
everybody's good-looking so it's like
when you and Gary Oldman come around it
adds so much credibility because people
go but was the only reason they're here
is they must be great actors no we were
just trying to be employed no and what
Gary did which was super super smart
yeah was to play Americans and he
started off doing accents and then when
I came out it did the same thing and it
took the casting directors didn't know
who we were but they would get that guy
in they didn't know that we were English
so you were sneaking into it we were
sneaking it yeah because now you look
especially backdoor in it right now you
look at you look at shows like like The
Walking Dead for example like there's so
many British actors that are doing
American parts this that's the thing we
also luckily for me anyway I have to say
there was a there was a moment that was
happening in America which was the there
was a little window of independent
filmmaking where Quentin came up through
and James Gray came up through and
before the the powers-that-be went oh
there's money and that will take it
right but just for
second there were these young young
filmmakers that were actually getting to
make films right for no money whatever
but there were great writers and you
know there was their films and I was
like I'll take that yeah and I went down
that road I didn't go down the big movie
road and I kind of have kept going down
that road as much as possible you get a
couple big movies though I've done a
couple of yeah but but know that well I
mean I like new directors I like
independent film and I like that world
and it's funny because I feel like
independent film in that that stuff is
what makes a real impact on people like
that's what people really try and
balance remember but when I when I told
my canon here that you were coming in
today he was like I loved him in the
Hulk say yeah that's fun for the kids
yeah I was like oh gonna do that yeah
about 15 years ago when you stopped
watching yourself I saw that one and and
and I took my boys to the premiere and
it was a green carpet not a red carpet
with the Hulk you know what it's fun now
and at that point your boys go like oh
my god this is what Dad does this is so
exciting basically they look at me like
they are the eye roll you can hear it
you know across the country they're
tired of your face they're tired of me
right there's a certain point that you
get to with your kids I don't know if
you have kids maybe seven months old oh
he loves my face I'm shooting blanks
you seen blanks yeah there's a point you
get to where you become the object of
ridicule when when is that point it's it
it's almost you can get it to the day
that they're generally about it's not 16
right then that's just door slamming and
fine but when they get to about 17 they
start to look at you and go did you just
say that you really just said that right
and they start quoting you and you
become the dad joke right you are that I
knew there's nothing you can do about
don't it's you can be the most serious
sky and well you're still the dad joke
you explain to them like do you know
like a lot of people
my work think that I'm really cool like
that joke they don't think that's the
same right you you literally are it's a
losing wicket you are you are so did you
raise them here I the two one the two I
have the two American boys now have a do
they have a British accent though always
curious about that they okay so odd I
mean cuz that's the worst quote I was
thinking of like if they're gonna quote
you'd be like oh cool yeah of course
they'll do that he writes have you so
you literally don't stand a chance now
kids but there comes an age it's coming
to you yeah and it's but you know how
old are they now they are now I have a
20 year old a 22 year old and a 33 year
old okay so the 33 year old must be at
the point where the relationship is gone
folks are London he's a man right he's a
man but he'd probably still be rolling
his eyes okay so that would I don't
think if it goes away okay that's tough
here so you so when you started working
with Quentin Tarantino what was when you
did Reservoir Dogs like what was he like
as a first-time director because that
movie was so kind of outside the box and
to me what's the most interesting about
Quentin Tarantino is he was doing his
own thing from the beginning and it's
one thing to do that now but it takes a
lot of balls to just show up on the
scene and be like nope I know it's not
what like anything else right now but
this is what we're doing I'll tell you
well first of all things to remember
about that he'd he had to sell true
romance which he'd written right he had
to sell Natural Born Killers which he'd
written right to make Reservoir Dogs
Rome which he'd written he don't he got
and he was a was he's younger than me
he's only he's about three years at
younger me he's a baby
mm-hmm so when I met him he that was his
I didn't know at that time that's his
third script when you read that script
if you go back and look at the actual
look at the script which I think it's
published you can tell is it there's a
great director going around it just from
reading it oh I see cuz you can you can
start to picture it you can see what has
you yeah I mean there is stage direction
just know yeah
you're looking at going to be in this I
want to and that was pretty much I think
everyone's reaction when they read it
was like oh no I'm doing this if I can
yeah and that's continued to today every
if he is the same person as I met when
when he was pacing around my little
apartment in in California going out how
we can do this well beam and and
throwing ideas and stuff around when we
were at the very very beginning this is
exactly the same guy he just has more
bullets now right he has more equipment
so he's now and he's made eight films it
can do was doing that can can do a
couple of things that aren't great it
can either people sell out and they just
make quite Busters or people get so kind
of full of their artistic vision that
they don't have a grasp on what they're
doing anymore and just go so against the
rental walls so very he's just doing
what he will he is determined so but
he's about to hang it up right he's
almost done said that he said ten yeah
but he also said that hateful eight
wasn't gonna come out after that script
leaked and then thank god it did right I
was rehearsing a play when that happened
and I was I got the script
the original script and by the way I
wish well we did a reading of it in LA
it's such a great script I mean it it
might be one of no but the original one
the original one the one that came out
it's great it's great so play is yeah
it's fate it's extraordinary what he did
but the original one as well is just
it's worth it's worth the region where
the check but yeah so that you basically
if your phone lights up and it's Quentin
you're just going please please please
and he was you know and that's where net
when he was like hey I'm doing this
thing I've got this thing for you and
you go thanks very much when do I show
up now you don't even have to read it by
the way do you get when when Tarantino
movies come out that you're not in they
break your heart yeah II get insecure
like oh my god he doesn't like me nor
insecure okay it's sad you do so sad oh
my I was trying to do I was supposed to
do inglourious basterds he written
part of me in it mm-hmm and I couldn't
because I was doing lie to me that's
just about stuff like to me and I was so
angry just I was furious with myself and
and just with the world because they
don't come around right his there's just
good writing like that doesn't come
around it's very very rare yeah and and
and you can rely on Quentin to write
well for you or for anybody
yeah but but he he has like a little
troupe that he adds to and takes away
from as he's pushing through life and
and we're all hands up I'll walk across
the back I'm fine but you know that
you're gonna get something I would be so
scared though of being one of those
people in the troupe to kind of get left
behind as you said right people go I've
been terrified of that yes you are a new
bunny and you should be right and and
quite rightly and we all are yeah but
we've had a shot yeah you you know we've
all had a crack at it
uh-huh they're very I mean I think of
Sam Jackson as his leading man
I think he's his it's like in like a
like Cary Grant would have been to
whoever it may have been like De Niro to
Scorsese Tom Hardy Christopher Nolan yes
you know but but Sam gets it right just
gets it and he he wanted to be in
Reservoir Dogs to Sam Jackson did he was
pissed off that he wasn't furious in
real life actually speaking about
missing out about salmon he gets really
angry like that it gets very quiet and
and I'd I'd worked with Sam but I
digress but I know it with Sam up here I
did a film with a really talented young
director when I first came out okay call
Jeff Stan
we did a funcle' jump in the boneyard we
did it showed up in the Bronx and around
New York and we were the only film
shooting out here you guys
won't make him films at that point
mm-hmm was it my fault it was all your
fault okay all right I lobbied against
it there Dinkins came to visit the sir
and he was wearing tennis whites and he
had pinkeye but Sam was in that film Sam
I had a small pattern Jeffery right I
think and Sam both had kind of small
like three scenes to do the next time I
saw Sam was in the makeup trailer in
Pulp Fiction I mean hi and we were about
to do our stuff in in in the diner
that's so cool and that's I mean I would
say Sam would be would would would would
probably agree that that that Quentin
changed his life like he did yeah do you
know when you're doing a line
specifically in those Tarantino movies
do you know when there's a line on the
page like that that's gonna be
one-on-ones it's done yep like when you
say like like I love you honey bunny
like that's never going to in Peaks the
stuff I die I haven't seen it but I had
some stuff to do with Jennifer Jason
Leigh mm-hm
and our relationship we just kept was
honey bunny that's almost said it during
a take bit Sam David by the way since
you haven't seen it I should let you
know a lot of your stuff is great you're
doing some good stuff we studied that
diner scene in senior year high school
in my English class for like half a
semester we shot that as a film oh
really just by itself it was the
beginning uh-huh and and he is typical
Quentin move but he just did the whole
section as its own film mm-hmm so John
and Sam were almost secondary players to
it oh well you know anyway he's is Sokka
and I Dre I knew the script because
Quentin actually read that so I'm
thinking you were the main character
more classic no it was bookends mm-hmm
just he wanted the film to begin and end
with this particular couple doing that's
awesome and yeah it from two different
perspectives and it's very clear well so
you you missed out on an inglorious
basterds I did I read that you but that
one I can understand cuz you know why me
was a big series in one scene I think it
was one sequence the law for that for
the men wanted me to do yes so that
makes sense but but couldn't be
therefore I read that you turned down
the Harry Potter the is that true that
you turn down the first Harry Potter
what's true there's two versions that
story tell me I'll tell you about yeah I
said yes to Harry Potter yeah because my
kids were I was reading it to my
children mhm
and and so I went to meet with the
director and said I kids have kill me if
I don't do this and they were really
cool and they and I think book three was
out or something and it was for Snape
and I and I I thought oh I can play him
I and I had a very different animal in
mind from what Alan did very but that's
so that's okay but because of different
people and then and then Tim Burton came
along with with monkey acting I wanna do
that I just wanted to play monkey so I
went yes to both okay
and so and and and the Harry Potter
people were really cool mmm-hmm and they
will fly you back and forth between
England and America so you can do make
both movies and it started to get I
started to go cross-eyed with the idea
of it and so I pulled out of the Harry
Potter thing I said thank you but I
can't
I cut the monkey
yeah I see no potential in this
franchise I'm gonna go my lunch box
Center so then why did you pick the
monkey movie I wasn't and I talked to my
boys about it because I they think it's
hilarious it's yeah it's really really
funny that you're not living in a bigger
house yeah I didn't want my life to be
franchised now that makes sense because
even I wanted to keep acting and I
thought there was a chance yeah
that I would have to stop at some point
because you're you're it I could see it
was gonna be huge and I knew it was
gonna be massive thing and is but not in
the way that I want to write be known no
I get that and and as big as it was for
Alan it was also when Alan passed as
much amazing work as that guy's done so
many people were like Snape Snape Snape
Snape Snape he was ready
that's he wanted he he was right do that
I spoke when I when I directed my only I
needed at one time he was he was an
actor that I kind of knew of the that
had directed him and Gary Oldman so I I
called Alan ARP I'd already spoken to
Gary about it I called Alan up and said
and just it's taught me down off the
ledge a little bit about um how do you
do this and he said get some sleep
that was his nose very get some sleep
cuz you're not gonna have any for a long
time and he was right for about two
years you don't and it and it you know
he did it he's the guy in the in the
with the figures in the box and
write-ups he's Snape right he did it
it's a story that I tell but really it's
not that interesting I think it's
interesting I mean I was right there and
then I actually think the most
interesting thing is like this head you
got on your shoulders that that doesn't
drive you crazy you know anything that
you can you can put that even the little
thing that you just did where you said
Alan did it differently but that's okay
we're different people and you move on
like the way you can put things in the
proper perspective but I think if I
actually do think about it like if I had
I wonder if it would have been an uphill
struggle because I would I know how I
would like to have the character to have
looked and everything is a toy in a box
right when you when you have those
franchises franchises so my toy wouldn't
have been that one I mean I don't know
right and they want to sell that toy if
they were gonna know you're gonna play
it this way that's like real artistic
integrity to to specifically know what
you want to be remembered for I want to
be remembered in the Vegas way I just
want any but I want ten or ip's on
Twitter and I'm good yeah I mean as my
boys are becoming oh they are men it's
like what do you wanna do right what do
you want to do do any of them want to
act no my one in London is an actor
mm-hmm but my my little uns they I don't
know I hope not
yeah no one's a musician and one I think
is a director to be honest I think
that's what happened was it difficult
for the older one when the younger ones
came because like mommy's always and
you're in a different place in your life
you're gonna focus on these little kids
and he's gonna be like hey what about me
I've been over here for years that
happens yeah and it and you've got a
you've got a you you got to push through
and either goes well it doesn't but you
know yes of course of course then you
have to understand that he was born that
way that's what I mean the bike as a 23
year old you're not gonna be the father
that you are to these young kids right
no but you you're you're hopefully best
mates right that's what you aim at it's
also good to have a practice one that's
the perspective what was a David Lynch
like to work with on Twin Peaks because
everybody's got David Lynch stories
coming off that show sure yeah well mine
is it was my David Lewis story I I find
him to be a gentle soul really really
gentle soul which makes I
well he writes books about
Transcendental Meditation right yeah I
didn't know that yeah oh yeah he's like
one of the guys cuz he frightens people
he don't frighten me
good he just makes me giggle i I I
showed up on set he was about halfway
through it I guess when we started
shooting our stuff he said what's he
sound like and I did a voice for him he
went I like that do that okay and then
he would he gives really I haven't I
haven't seen it but I know how my
character ends up this is how it's been
so spoiler alert yeah but when I was
getting sharp his note to me was his
note he was think rag doll Elvis I think
of him I and that's why that's I mean I
love him yeah and we when they'd said
Twin Peaks we just went yep whenever you
know however whatever you know the rest
of the Shakira lyrics I remember
thinking I remember Davis which you guys
may not have seen is a razor head yeah
yeah now and the woman within the who
lives in the raid radiator with the
incredibly swollen cheeks and all the
umbilical cords holding like rain never
understood it right didn't care to
understand it just enjoyed it
well yeah that's what we were talking
about integrity that guy yeah I mean
incredible we had with Kyle MacLachlan
in here recently and that's why I was
asking him is that you know these
questions that we watch Twin Peaks and
we have like what did that mean
and we at like is that is that something
that you asked David on the set like I
don't work you don't ask he he might
because he said no he knew everything he
did what kyle has to kind of know I mean
I I saw Kyle I worked with that version
of his character great one I guess
there's three right um II Cooper's yeah
there is I mean there's only a new one -
yeah yeah great to cure three yeah
anyway so I'm working with this guy with
the with the mullet and and the right
guy really going down and so that's the
actor that we're working with you know
and then we're having a break and have a
cup of tea and waiting for the cameras
to get set up and all of that and then
we wrap out our staff me and Jennifer
and then I'm in makeup getting sort of
scrubbed up and he's getting ready to
play the other guy right all right
that's as much information okay I'll
keep you know and you're told to keep
quiet don't never watch it is weirdness
that you see I kind of want to watch the
show even though you're on it just to
see one on earth was I filming that one
definitely well I'm not allowed to watch
my kids have put a kind of embargo on it
because especially my 22 year old
because he wants to see the first one
right he wants to see the whole thing go
through the movie and then we'll sit
much similar to do a whole gonna get
some title of yeah yeah that's cool as
much as they make fun they're still
interested Lynch's as cool as it gets
how does how does David Lynch's style of
writing directing but you probably work
with him more as a director compared
with Tarantino that just thought
different animals completely different
yeah now is I've heard David Lynch is
very married to the words on the page
it's absolutely specific is that the
same way Quentin is or is it more of a
in a different way but yes the thing the
thing that I find with Quentin is he's
already written the improvisation in you
know it's it's that's Quentin's dig
right you're going word specific on
eternity
because you're not beating it don't you
know he's done it for you right you're
absolutely using your Harry with David
script there's a plan that you don't
know I don't I like I don't know the
world of Twin Peaks I don't know why my
character might say a B or C it's
specifically there for a reason
Quentin has that too but but but you
just give it up to him
right do you find that that lack of
information adds to the performance then
like are you performing under that guise
of not knowing or do you have to kind of
act still assured yeah actually I I
quite liked it
I'm the only other guy that I've worked
with who does does that is Woody Allen
mmm and with woody and and I got he was
gonna send me the script and then he
decided not to he wrote me a long letter
and then said here's your bits and I'll
see you on set and then when I worked
with him it was again different we were
up here and he came to the scripts and
said okay this is a good line that will
get you a laugh um all of this stuff do
whatever you want to whatever you get
use this line this is a good line too
yeah this one will get you laugh too and
he'd say but the rest of it do whatever
you feel improvised Woody Allen
yeah but he wanted it right he wanted
that freedom for my particular character
a thing